lüthi wo früher canetti sie wohl gerne
mal einen joint raucht happy few sophie
stimmt das
das stimmt ja das stimmt stellte bmw
bmw.etr sie einmal freude philosophie
haben eine struktur schlägerungen dienen
als bier trinkt und schöne schluckt wie
und den große theorie schwingen mit
ihnen über alles ganz banale geschichte
und und sagt wie die teufel der
oberfläche geblieben schönen ist einfach
in eurer gruppe beziehung nicht retten
aber ganz einfach die sachen nicht immer
über schwere komplex i
entscheidungsfindungsprozess es ist
schönes aussehen leichtigkeit des seins
eigentlich in dieser geschichte geht es
um einen der gerne musiker geworden wäre
und stattdessen eine finanzkünstler
wurde
[Musik]
udo pastörs ist in die heimat seiner
vorfahren zurückgekehrt um etwas zu
bewegen
er will mit seinem herzensprojekt zeigen
also fahren wir nach gesenkt und den
größten slum von angolas hauptstadt
luanda
[Musik]
wo heute kinder fußball spielen stand
bis vor kurzem eine industrieruine die
einstige seifenfabrik war brutstätte für
malaria mücken und rückzugsort für
banditen dann kam busters macht er eine
art gemeinschaftszentrum daraus und
verbreitete aufbruchstimmung aber stimme
dass er der beste fußballer hinter gegen
zwei fragt er diesen knirps der kleine
bejahen hart arbeiten und dran glauben
band schaffte es bis nach ganz oben
kleine wunder allenthalben früher
verkauften diese frauen früchte pastor
sagte mach doch säfte daraus so verdient
der meere
heute sind sie unternehmerinnen dass
entwicklungshilfe geleistet wird man
dass es so habe das entwickelt
verschiedene namen modern innovativ wie
entwicklungshilfe sich mehr weigern nach
einer jungen lüth zeige dass mit
kreativität kann man sich selber helfen
und und das ist eigentlich dieses mal
message queue service creative city
das angebot ist riesig und von bastos
offeriert diese kinder interessieren
sich für elektronik andere lernen
englisch unternehmen computerkurse
und wieder am trainieren capoeira alles
dank bastos der hier für viele hält und
vorbild ist hier im aachener dom in die
energie die motivieren andere lücke
werde zum beispiel kopieren ich verglüht
es machen fachmann ist gemacht hat wäre
steffi gegründet das wird dieses mal so
es wird für kopiert und ich finde das
gut
fördere das auch der ball am rollen
panzer unterrichts als rolle bringen
jung und alt treffen sich zum
gedankenaustausch
bastos berät sie stellt arbeitsplätze
ich internet 3d drucker know how und
finanzielle starthilfe zur verfügung
das grundproblem ist dass sie nur noch
große finden 4x möglichkeit gefunden hat
vor der prototypen in serienproduktion
fachen umzuwandeln
euro entfiel produktion sich große
problem durch afrika hält dies
honico probleme kissed a girl group sa
[Musik]
es gebe hier viele probleme sagt sie
korruption sei eines davon aber sicher
nicht das einzige hier wird er bewundert
in der schweiz massiv kritisiert seit
der name in den sogenannten paradise
papers auftauchte vertrauliche
unterlagen die den medien zugespielt
wurden und zeigen wie reiche steuern
vermeiden
bastos indes wird dafür kritisiert wie
er den milliardenschweren staatsfonds
angolas verwaltet einer der vorwürfe
betrifft so genannte private equity
fonds die er managt einfach gesagt außer
westliches kapital das er in projekte
investiert dafür kassieren zu hohe
gebühren
das sich im höheren bereich b ich will
ich in afrika agieren und wie ich so
genannte thema fotos h also jedoch
natürlich die fusion thema fonds und das
führt dazu dass jeder mehr aufwand in
afrika komplexität ist größer
bastos soll wunderbares bewirken aus
geld zukunft machen indem er projekte
finanziert die eine rendite abwerfen und
angola wirtschaftlich und sozial
voranbringen
etwa 16 großfarmen die 72.000 hektaren
land bewirtschaften ziel
hier produzieren weniger importieren
[Musik]
bastos und sein team sollen drei
milliarden dollar in solche und ähnliche
projekte stecken
bisher haben sie allerdings erst etwa
ein drittel des geldes angelegt das
problem es gebe schlicht nicht genug
vielversprechende projekte was das ist
bestens vernetzt
bis in höchste regierungskreise er gelte
als machen sagt er
als einer der lieferung cola ist
eigentlich ein reiches land es gibt
erdöl und diamanten trotzdem verdienen
mehr als die hälfte der angolaner nur
zwei dollar pro tag
sie wollen es auf die sonnenseite des
lebens schaffen
alle sind sie weisen und hatten darum
schlechte karten
bis bastos kam ihr weißen haus
unterstützt und ihnen tennisstunden
zahlte das bricht ihrem monotonen alltag
fordert sie koordinativ und bedeutet
eine chance sie können später touristen
tennisstunden geben und so geld
verdienen
vom richtigen stürmer rückte war eine
sehr schwere weiß nur die videos ich
sehe die sich auch lieferungen bis james
liegt sie ganz schön hunde verräter
sachlich so kommt das nächste mal auch
wenig dass verloren haben sie richtige
muskelpakete zimmer waren sie mal
richtig geld verdienen nämlich den ist
die erste million hätte was wird sich
auf situation kommt und campina tennis
motoren kommt das erst im herbst wird
sie alle sache für ihre kollegen auf und
nach eine sache für sich und er wird sie
auch für mich was ein sie mit ihrem die
erste million auf waren gerüstet sieht
es nach dh weniger wieder investiert
beziehungen und firmen aufbauen wie ein
reiskorn die kinder müsse man fördern
und fordern ist boss der selber fünf
kinder von drei frauen hat überzeugt
man dürfe sie nicht zu leicht machen
er selber habe es auch nicht leicht
gehabt und habe es nicht trotzdem
sondern deshalb zu etwas gebracht im
leben ist der 50 jährige überzeugt ist
schwarz also ich messling miniermotte
erschließt und die harley klettern und
haben wenn ich liebe diese schuhe haben
um auf zeit ja die vorträge und so
weiter und so fort
und das für mich sehr dass wir als
kleiner bub extrem schwierig sei und der
habe ich kann ich daher gibt's card
zeige dass trotzdem trotz der der
montage kann es schaffen
bastos ist der sohn einer schweizerin
seiner solotournee uhrmacher familie und
eines angolanischen studenten früh
entdeckte er sein unternehmerisches
talent fing als unternehmensberaterin
und wurde reich
rg schnell duschen in einer stunde werde
weiter gefilmt sagt mir bastos
treffpunkt ist diese baustelle in
luandas innenstadt
aber der parkplatz von dr jean-claude
der ein lizenziat in bwl von der uni
fribourg hat bleibt leer
hier wird am der einst höchsten gebäude
angolas gearbeitet
darüber wollen wir reden aber wo ist
bastos für seine medienberater insgesamt
begleiten drei diese dreharbeiten ist er
nicht erreichbar
nach über fünf stunden tauchte plötzlich
auf zuerst ein kurzes briefing durch mit
seinen pressechef missverstanden ist
mein selbstverständnis dass sie ihre
fällige führung
irgendwo da dank dass tod und witzig ist
ich bin der mittelständler sollten das
fertig wer ist dieser mann voll
konzentriert oder beginnen wir uns
auseinander zu leben wenn ich das
fertige ausdruck für das grundbuch es
gibt verschiedene phasen
es gibt phasen umreißt nur sekunden usa
sprachen sich nach kurz besprechen
maximum
ich weiß dass wir interessiert oder
nicht interessiert wo rapid am entenfang
sobald er aus vorsicht weiter ist
schaltete er ganz profi sofort das
funkmikrofon aus dass ich ihn angesteckt
habe
aus erklär ich es gut selber dezember
1980 meter hoch und beinhalten ein hotel
büros wohnungen und ein zentrum für
kulturelles und soziales leben ein turm
wir bastos gehören der andere dem
staatsfonds und genau das ist das
problem aus sicht von kritikern bastos
trägt hier zwei hüte der staatsfonds den
er verwaltet investiert nämlich in ein
projekt das bastos als geschäftsmann
lanciert hat
hat sie doch kein trassen konflikt mit
dem projekt somit kosten splitter das
ist zu spüren dass der staat von trust
und natürlich von der economy of scale
profitieren und es ist für mich von 30
vom economy of scale profitieren also
ist es relativ interessant
interessante lösung der über 7000 weiß
mein fazit der vom staat vor ort
ja aber wenn sie wie viel uhr geht mir
internet viel andere verhalf für die
sondern sie haben einfach power das ist
verdienen riesenvorteil
also es frieren win win situation für
sie ja für mich dann sind das sind
natürlich economy of scale oder wenn
diese nicht auf und und und weniger
profitieren wenn sie wüssten nicht dass
diese nicht auf wird müssen zahllose
aber das ist hier jetzt 40 600 tonnen
war nicht jetzt schon den hut müsste
jetzt trag und jetzt kann man das zwei
fragen und der verein ist gut dass wir
den fans gut verrühren für mich ist es
gut also für beide ist von vorteil als
zuschuss wenn man also statt
zwangsverwalter dass man alles mit
projektron investiere für das weiß jetzt
nicht wie andere das leistet aber wenn
es für sie kräfte st für die für die
andere berufe der stadt von und für mich
ist das eine win-win-situation verwenden
will fachleute sagen mir dass wir unter
angepasst ja in afrika sind einfach mal
wie wir dabei aber da kann ich dann
notiert für kommentare zu machen
[Musik]
neuer tag neue verspätung diesmal eine
gute halbe stunde african style sei das
sagt bastos hier müsse man eben mit dem
flogen leute die bastos beruflich kennen
beschreiben ihn als hyperaktiv und
knallhart er selber nennt sich topf sind
sie aber beruhte rama vom legales lotet
ausreizt
er sagte zu mir blieben immer illegal
handelt immer als lenz braucht immer
best practice volk sprach nach hohen
grafisch bis zehn minuten nach einer
grundvoraussetzung damit los oder ist
das vertrauen das ist vertraulich
aber das rennen machen und core i5
minute bis zumindest rose
[Musik]
inzwischen hat bastos medial eine alte
geschichte eingeholt die mit seiner
aktuellen tätigkeit nichts zu tun hat
2011 wurden er und sein damaliger
geschäftspartner in zusammenhang mit
einer firmen liquidation in der schweiz
wegen mehrfacher ungetreuer
geschäftsbesorgung verurteilt
heute ist sein strafregister wieder leer
der handelszeitung sagt der damals
moralisch gesehen sei er unschuldig er
habe einen vierfachen vater lohn bezahlt
und so dessen privatkonkurs verhindert
degen war froh wenn es endlich wird auch
in ruhe mit dem hartz iv sollte sich mit
der geschäftsbetrieb und vorwärts bürger
ich hab das dann und und ich weiß jetzt
was man darf annehmen darf mache und ich
hatte einen mix wenn sie ethische frage
geht dann muss man die einfach den
sprachen vor analyse laut tages anzeiger
ging es damals um mehr und bastos habe
auch indirekt sich selbst bereichert
[Musik]
der tagungsort gewünschten fotos sie
sich selber berichtet alice waters ist
das ist das eine das ist ein falsches
sagt das ist nach einem euro sind selbst
berichten sondern wir sind
verurteilt wurde er wegen ungetreuer
geschäftsbesorgung werke bei denen
zahlen wo man hat wo man nicht hatte
dörfer machen
nach der liquidation sternen es ging um
verschiedene zahlungen eine davon kam
bei wirtschaftlicher betrachtung ihnen
selbst zugute so das gericht
sie hätten sich damit sehr wohl indirekt
selbst bereichert außerdem ist von
75.000 euro die rede die bastos und sein
partner in bar abheben und einem dritten
übergeben haben wollen
der bestreitet jedoch das geld bekommen
zu haben
service zahlen kommissionszahlungen wo
mir transparente buchhaltung hand und
nach einer entsprechenden beleg gelten
dass ich zwanzig aber mir hat
transparente buchhaltung tor und verdarb
den scat ins gericht entschied wenig zu
wenig und lage aber sehr düster das
verbot empfunden wenn man selber halte
guido hand also während nicht versteckt
sondern sie jeweils immer transparent
sind im urteil steht von einer
rechtmäßigen provision könne nicht die
rede sein
falls das geld tatsächlich übergeben
worden wäre sei es eine rechtswidrige
zahlung und diese zahlung hätte
offenkundig keinem anderen zweck dienen
können aus der bestechung des dritten
außerdem habe bastos partner eine faust
erkunden begangen weil er das geld
falsch verbuchen ließ
[Musik]
so kommt mir das alles je länger desto
mehr vor
noch gestern hieß es dieser flug sei
unmöglich zu viele termine heute die
wundersame wende
wir starten in einem gecharterten
privatflugzeug richtung kabine ins
grenzgebiet zwischen ambulant im kongo
[Musik]
hier hat der us geschäftsmann einen
tiefseehafen lanciert und später den
starts von tränen verwaltet mit an bord
geholt
immerhin habe er hier starts vor gelder
investiert sport und seine kritiker 2
milliarden hatte nämlich noch gar nicht
angelegt die management gebühren
kassiert er trotzdem egal irgendwo um es
ist gar nicht investiert und flüsterte
millionen von büchern
was ist so bis sind sodann viel ala
punkt kommt wo sieht unterschrift
handbuch das verwachsen und so im
durchschnitt nur pizza sie analysieren
die verschiedenen team sind 80
spezialisten finanzspezialisten der
techniker und diente das alles
analysieren und allure und dann können
wir die verschiedenen berichten über und
und denn die note pries verhandle mit
dann je nach was nach dem was sie den
kunden handelten analyse und der hund
vor handlich und da geht es ja
langweilig und es sei denn sie das team
plötzlich stirbt also stimmen möglich
aber dann haben sie trotzdem damit
leichter und und sind herrschte kam und
was das läuft natürlich ständig dass
eine maschine läuft
bastos will symbolisch fahnen auf einer
fels ausschüttung platzieren
aber die chinesen die hier für den
bauern haben die fahnen längst montiert
wenn wir jetzt gar den tisch
das ist dass solche sachen macht 1600
neue arbeitsplätze sollen im hafen
entstehen und durch die wirtschaftlichen
impulse die sich daraus ergeben
insgesamt 30.000 arbeitsplätze so passt
das großzügige schätzung
insofern ist das projekt von nationalem
interesse für angola
[Musik]
der neu gewählte präsident war bereits
vor ort wird er bastos die stange halten
oder ist sein höhenflug bald vorbei mit
dem sohn des früheren präsidenten ist
bastos eng befreundet und der ist auch
der chef des staatsfonds
wer sein geld busters anvertraute normal
wäre es die risiken zu streuen
kritiker vermuten bastos habe bisher von
biene oder inkompetenz profitiert bastos
widerspricht es gehe nur um leistung
es ist es vertrauen als ich als ich eine
positive truck rekorde und es ist es
verstand ist für die lokale realität und
gegebenheit und es ist das verständnis
der in der land und das risiko
obwohl das das fernlicht ein schweizer
investor und entwirrt risiko im sinnvoll
die hand größe zwischen checklisten und
main gestand sie die sache auf denen
täglich einen haken und man muss
trotzdem keine reine zu überholen das
trotzdem über wenn ich jetzt schon den
nächsten schritt machen und damit sie
damit sie kultur verstehen sieht
realität verstellen um überhaupt keine
risiken abschätzen
und das war nur der kulturbund und das
verstört und kritik an merkel steht
damit das ist ein seltener mix und ich
glaube ich an so einer seltenen links
in der tat ein seltener mix dieser mann
eine mischung aus macher visionäre und
wohltäter aber auch ein schritt so
player und mischler würde ich sagen
bastos sieht es einmal mehr ganz anders
ich glaube nicht dass ich weiter playern
ist das anders
die erinnerung und das macht mir freude
strategie definiert relativ relativ
klare guide und gewohnt klare
zielsetzung gekommen
[Musik]